[Music]
so
in ireland ireland
in ireland's highest court right now
they have
recently ruled that subway sandwiches
are way too sugary to legally be defined
but as bread joe just pictured everyone
in the court with wigs
well i pictured a bunch of leprechauns i
knew it
i pictured kills i pictured all kills is
that iris or that scottish scottish
what's irish it's kind of close mcgregor
man
it's the [ __ ] it's the it's the
button it's the belt buckle button shoes
you know what i mean oh okay i don't
know what he's talking about
you know the fighting irish oh okay yeah
yeah
yeah all right this one all the way up
to the highest court yes
because this has been a five-year battle
i don't know
[ __ ] subway no fook lockers
since 2006. you know you know what's you
know what's wild it's because
out there i don't know if it's europe or
england or all of them
they say all of them all of them all the
pools over there
they have a limit to how much sugar they
can put into the food that's
awesome yeah that's why this [ __ ] tastes
so good man and it's like
balanced so they're saying the bread is
too sugary yes okay so
this all started back in 2006. you
tell them [ __ ] yeah when uh
one of the franchisees they were
claiming that it was
owed a tax refund because of the fact
that
there is this uh this vat act of 1972
that it pretty much says like you will
get a zero percent
tax on foods that are considered um
healthy oh my gosh i'm forgetting staple
it's a staple like a staple food
like a potatoes potato rice
so staple food items get no tax right
but because subway had been getting
taxed all this time they're like what
the [ __ ] bread is a staple food
we're making sandwiches why are we
getting tech
so then don't text me on my sandwiches
[Laughter]
they're magically delicious like charms
my healthy charms my hair oh me lucky
charms not so lucky anymore
yeah so they actually found
that the dough baked for subway
sandwiches has a sugar content of
roughly 10
of the weight of the flower content holy
crap
in order to be considered a bread
product it must not be more than two
percent in total wow
of flour really ten percent sugar that's
all
[ __ ] up ten percent the weight of its
flour content wow
so then so it's so bread is two percent
so this [ __ ] is like what is it it's
like cake now or what i guess so yeah
cake buns man yeah so that's the reason
why they have that
call me sandwich's cake the reason why
they have
they drew that that line there is
because
they like the fact of it being a staple
food is supposed to be like healthy for
the whole
for everyone right but then if it's like
don't what about birthdays
what about my birthday i'm supposed to
making sandwiches with people's
birthdays every day
change it all to like cake may i have
the italian cake the cold cut trio cake
we put candles in the sandwiches did you
know that a
six inch white bread roll has five grams
of sugar which is similar
to that of an oreo cookie whoa
oreo cookie oreo cookies are wild yep
damn that's crazy all of our food has
uh sugar because they figured out what
is
the best so it's it's called the bliss
point so scientists figured out
how much sugar makes us feel really good
but also
addicted to that product so almost
everything that we have
has actual sugar because i cut out sugar
for like a month
and then when i started looking into
labels i was like [ __ ] how the [ __ ] does
chips have sugar like this has sugar
it's all salty like
and bread like when you eat bread you're
like how the [ __ ] does this have sugar
and then i found out all of this stuff
when i went down the rabbit hole
of um sugars and everything we eat man
did you know toothpaste had sugar
really one does i mean like back in the
day all of them i mean it's sweet at
least in the u.s because if you go to
asia it's saltier
that's true it is saltier yeah that is
true
no but yeah they so they looked into all
six of the company's bread options so
even the one that you might think is
really healthy like the nine grain multi
seed or the honey oat
oh honey probably has the most they were
all deemed too sugary
damn just change their recipe enough and
then they'll get the
but you're not going to dick people the
way the other ones are not going to dick
them anymore they kind of dick me now
that should taste like [ __ ]
no someone's good i don't like you know
you can do a subway too that people
don't know for a healthier option you
can tell them to um
hollow out the bread yeah what what do
you carve it out no they just use their
hand and they just like really
work much like they so yeah me too so
it's like they
then you get more stuff in there so so
is that really
no they don't actually give you more
stuff it feels like more though
it feels like you know you're eating a
healthier sandwich because it's not all
bread oh wow
you know what they really need to solve
is how the [ __ ] do you make
fresh baked stale bread it's fresh but
it comes out stale like it's disgusting
you don't like subway not their bread
i like the bologna ever since i started
eating jersey mikes i can't go back to
assembling
jersey mikes do you think they have even
more sugar in their bread
probably oh jersey mike's
no it's
[Laughter]
jersey mike brother get some sandwiches
brother
join doodle paper that's what i'm
forgetting sir marshall do they even
have
sandwiches in hawaii like a hawaiian
sandwich i got musubi
no that's not a sandwich though don't
have the hawaiian buns
yeah oh yeah that's super good that
that's
like it has a lot of sugar not actually
it has some sugar yeah that's a real
cake
it's so good though that is good i could
just eat the bread by itself yeah
wine bread so fire bro literally just
all you need is
portuguese just some butter toast
sesame season i like to make sloppy joes
with that
sloppy joe sliders i use it with
everything what hawaiian bread hawaiian
bread yeah
hamburger hamburger it's so soft they
use it at shake shack oh that's a potato
bar it's not hawaiian
it's not hawaiian bread though no no
it's kind of similar though it tastes
like it yeah the texture is kind of soft
like that
man you get checked here hard it's
called potato bun fact check me yep
better watch out dude you're in the
wrong hood
it's just it's so sweet that it's really
good with like salty
meat you know what i'm saying so
whenever i have like even when i have
like leftover thai food like
like the beef stuff like some beef kapow
i'll throw it in
yeah you don't know how kapow no it's
like ground beef
it's a sound effect on the english menu
it'll it'll be called like basil beef or
something like that oh i had that
yeah beef
[Laughter]
a whole menu of a restaurant it's just
awesome
it's like [ __ ] pointing sounds like
chicken satay
[Music]
yummy what would you call that
restaurant
i don't know pootie's world i don't know
pootie's world
bam yeah emerald
what is he up to exclamation point bam
bam
that's kind of fire what's your guys
favorite sandwich from
just in general hands down best you mean
like kind of sandwich
turkey provolone vietnamese sandwich for
me
oh i like a cold special philly cheese i
like cold cuts too italian style
i like a nice dip you know what i'm
saying like a french dip
yeah but then like a roast beef dip yeah
but i went to um i went to a food truck
in arizona where they did like an asian
dip
because it was like a fusion food truck
and it was like a pork
sandwich and then he had kind of like a
um
like a a broth that came with it and
then you did the oh
man it was soul fire yeah it's really
good that just
made me think of beer yeah like if they
were media
media it's a goat right yeah different
types but yeah they make it with gold
they got beef ones too my favorite
sandwich place to go to y'all have been
an erla sandwich though yes
earl sandwich is so fine
i don't know it's something about it
it's just a sandwich but it's so good i
heard it's 15
sugar that's probably what it is the
bread is um
oh you know what kind of bread is really
on point all the time is lobster roll
bread i don't even know what that is it
tastes like a big [ __ ]
toast it's probably just a lot of butter
butter
to the lime it's not sugar it's butter
but when you pull apart that bread
grilled cheese bread did y'all ever um
put just hot dogs in a regular piece of
like white bread oh yeah
yeah that's ghetto fabulous good old
days my grandma used to um
get like a piece of wonder bread and
then she would
grill like a sausage and then wrap the
sausage up in the wonder bread with the
uh saran wrap so then it's like hella
tight
and we just sit there we unwrap it and
we eat it like that that's cute
no cheese that is cute nah
you know what i do now when i'm feeling
fancy i [ __ ]
put a little tortilla melt some cheese
on it and then roll the hot dog up in
that
oh next level it's a case of hot dog
case a hot dog
case a wiener quesadilla sounds like
something to serve about taco bell
yeah try a new case of wiener crunch it
does sound like this
i saw someone do they did a story and
then someone we know
and they had a flower tortilla and then
they put peanut butter
wait that's weird to you that's not
weird to you i make peanut butter and
jelly
tortillas it sounds weird as [ __ ] to me
what yeah
it's just bread that's not bread yeah
it's flat bread bro
it's literally just flat bread i could
imagine
a tortilla like a flour tortilla with
cinnamon butter and sugar that sounds
pretty good
yeah we used to do that oh okay with
butter cause there's still it's so
because for us we eat it with savory
dishes it's not a dish
sweet stuff is like my brain can't
complain it's like getting white rice
and then putting peanut butter on it you
never had mango sticky rice
yeah oh son
that's a way to eat rice like this
thirty percent each other
okay maybe that was the wrong one but no
but okay look i was about to bring that
up that's why because i
i do that all the time i'll take a
flower tortilla not a conscious kid
because that's weird i take flour
you're pretty close though peanut butter
might as well just not as different it
is different it is different
but that's how we view it desserts
they're all basically like tortillas
crepe but it's fluff it's fluffier it's
not
it's not yeah like the flavor is
different and it's not as thick as a
tortilla like
like crepes it's this really thin like
you can see the light through it
pancake warm up one more tortilla put
some peanut butter and jelly in that
[ __ ] roll it up have you ever gotten a
sope bottom
that's the same [ __ ] you might as well
sofa
peanut butter i make s'mores with
sulfate bottles
i'm saying this [ __ ] right now but then
we make puzzles which is a tortilla with
cinnamon and sugar
but you fry it um that is true you see
what i'm saying i know that's how it was
made
they're all the same ingredients just
different they just [ __ ] goopy
here's what i do for texture too i'll
make the peanut butter and jelly
tortilla i'll take some [ __ ] cereal
sprinkle it on
sprinkle it inside then roll it up give
you a little crunch you know how to eat
dude
you know how to eat your [ __ ] junk i
know how to eat my [ __ ] junk food
[Music]
do
you